Kevin and Damon are party promoters but  they don't have enough money to make  ends meet so they have to take on  another job cleaning these big mansions  in the Hollywood Hills and then they  realize that they're actually in  LeBron's house LeBron who James you want  to trick famous people into thinking  LeBron throwing a party hell yeah  [Music]  we have these major big players damn  buddy where'd you come from  time to go I was like oh [ __ ] that's  little Wayne come on coaches Back That  Ass Up You know what I'm saying I have  backed my ass up many a times  foreign  you can't have a house party without Kid  and Play that was the icing on the cake  you never know who's pulling up  it was just wild man it's wild  you good [ __ ] we done [ __ ] up the  koala